Той день зруйнував життя родини Генч.
Дві молоді жінки та три дівчинки загинули
від підпалу їхнього будинку 29 травня 1993 року.
Спробуйте уявити мій стан.
Уявіть, що п’ятеро ваших найрідніших людей –
матір, батька, брата чи сестру – вбили.
Їхній будинок, все нажите підпалили.
Що б ви робили? Хочеться померти.
Але життя триває і я до кінця житиму з цим болем.
Мевлюде Ґенч втратила у пожежі двох дочок,
двох онучок і племінницю.
Ще 14 членів родини отримали життєвонебезпечні поранення.
Тут, де колись стояв будинок родини Ґенч,
про загиблих нагадують п’ятеро каштанових дерев.
Двоє членів родини загинули,
вистрибнувши з вікон. Троє дівчат – у полум’ї.
Один з чотирьох підпалювачів жив на цій же вулиці,
майже навпроти родини Ґенч – 16-річний неонацист.
Загалом до багаторічного ув’язнення засудили чотирьох чоловіків.
Стаття – расизм.
Я не відчуваю ненависті щодо німців.
Ми усі брати й сестри.
Я відчуваю підтримку і німецької, і турецької держав.
Лише цих чотирьох злочинців я ненавиджу,
їх я ніколи не пробачу.
Підпал у Золінгені став піком хвилі
расизму і нападів на приїжджих,
яка захлеснула Німеччину в 90-х роках.
На трагедію особливо бурхливо відреагувала турецька діаспора.
Погроми й безлади в Золінгені не припинялися кілька днів.
Тоді тут була пішохідна зона.
Ми тоді йшли вниз і почули, що розповідали люди.
Це нас шокувало.
Наступного дня усе тут нагадувало воєнний стан.
На шлагбаумі горіли автомобільні шини.
Це була катастрофа.
Мевлюде Ґенч закликає своїх сусідів до примирення.
Роковини для 75-річної жінки та її чоловіка особливо важкі.
Попри це, їй важливо говорити про трагедію,
не дати про неї забути. Її підтримує онука.
Я хочу, щоб ми дивилися в майбутнє.
Щоб ми, люди, по-людськи поводились один з одним,
були дружніми, щоб не спричиняли один одному страждань.
У 1996 році Мевлюде Ґенч отримала
Хрест за заслуги перед ФРН за її боротьбу з расизмом.
Жінка вже 48 років у Німеччині.
Вона ніколи й думки не припускала покинути Золінген.
Нині про злочин нагадує меморіал, у формі зруйнованої свастики.